[Music]
i found out
later on that she in fact
had a sexually transmitted disease you
know at that point i had it as well and
so she knew about this she got the test
and she went ahead and slept with you
anyway i found out that she was taking
medication for it prior to meeting me so
she's known about this for a while
yo yo yo what's up this is john with the
dr john dalone's show hope you're doing
so well hope life's going good hope your
family is healthy
the summer is upon us
and i hope that y'alls
amidst all the chaos and all the madness
and all the whatever's going on that
you're finding some peace and some steps
and direction
moving forward so happy that you're here
on the
best mental health podcast of all time
in the history of humanity
uh i don't think podcasts have been
around for like 10 years maybe 12 years
it's kind of a little bit of uh
anyway so if you want to be on the sh
the greatest show ever
um
1-844-693-3291 that's
one or go to 1-844-693-3291
ask and don't forget
the new questions for humans decks are
out and you can go to johnalone.com and
check them out but d for real
they're not they're fun they're super
fun lots of laughs lots of like you know
they're fun but they're a tool
they're a tool to help you reconnect
with your buddies with your girlfriends
with someone you're on a date with with
your family they're a tool man and it
takes the heat for you so you can get
into some of these conversations so go
to john dolan.com and check those out
all right let's go to becca in whiteland
indiana what's up becca
hey
hey thank you so much for your time
i truly appreciate it thank you so much
i haven't got a good hey in a long time
that made my morning so what's up
okay um
i am struggling with i guess life not
turning out as i hoped it would um and
what i mean
at the army all um
what i mean by that is
i don't know if i want to say jealousy
but
my daughter
i think i feel like she basically has a
life that i want
and i know that sounds so wrong
i have a very good relationship with my
daughter okay um
and her but her boyfriend fiance he's
you know he's a very attentive
he
just asks if she needs help with me he
wants to do things with her he wants to
be with her he's financially stable
and you know again i am so happy for her
and you know i feel like i do have a
blessed life but
it's just kind of like i feel like
you know oh because i recently um i've
been reading your book
and it's kind of like brought a lot of i
guess bricks out yeah and um and i
recently just like about a week ago just
i just kind of had a meltdown yeah and
my daughter was witness to it and
so it was just it was hard i mean it was
like kind of everything just came up
and she was there for me and
you know it's just it's a lot so so yeah
how old are you
i am 54. 54. and i've been married for
um almost 32 years oh so you're still
married
yeah yeah
so
these are hard
when you are
man there's a lot here number one thank
you for being brave number two you're
not crazy okay you're not you're not
nuts all right
number three when you first start to
realize what you're carrying around
those bricks
i don't know somebody that has not had a
sit down and weep heavily i don't know
that person myself included when i
realized what i was carrying around it
was a lot
a i didn't realize i was even carrying
it b i didn't realize that those things
were still fresh so fresh to the to the
surface of my skin
three i didn't realize that i had
compromised so many of my other
relationships because of what i was
carrying right so all that stuff comes
at once and it's just a lot
um
yours is
yours is unique
in that
um
you're grieving something that you're
still living
well and i think a lot of it i know a
lot of it stems from my past because i
know i had
my childhood was pretty crappy
i mean it wasn't horrible but i mean it
was pretty crappy so i guess i had hoped
for better and
i just had hoped i guess that my
husband would honor me in the way that
her boyfriend seems to honor her
um for example she
you know we
she didn't want to have sex before
marriage and he has honored that and
i've even talked to her about it and
she's like no mom we haven't he's
you're peer pressuring her like come on
she's like no no no no no no no i'm
messing with you i'm messing with you uh
but but he he he he upholds her values
right her boundaries and probably vice
versa yeah so let me let me tell you two
things
one is he's not perfect
he's an illusion
okay sure there's no such thing as mr
right that that that entity doesn't
exist outside of a marvel show okay yeah
and it's really tempting to look at your
life as it has been and the compromises
you've made the things that your husband
has steamrolled over whether those are
your needs your desires your dreams your
where you want to live all those things
right there's gonna be there's gonna be
a litany of them
it's easy to look at
your what your daughter has and say
well if i had had that
what i'll tell you is that's great that
he he listens to her values it means he
loves her and that's great
and that's great that she trusts him
with her boundaries that's great
um
but you're superimposing your
regrets
on a fantasy and so i want to caution
you about that okay it's not real he
might be great he may be wonderful he's
not perfect okay the second thing is
have you sat down
any point over the last 30 years
and told your husband here's what i need
actually i did okay how'd it go we had
actually a long talk over the weekend
and i told him i said here's what i want
you to do for the first time in 30 years
right
no no we've actually done it before okay
it's just kind of like um
okay you know and he's like well am i in
trouble and no no no i just want to talk
but um i told him i said i want you to
make a list and you have things that you
think that
i could do to make our marriage better
um or whatever and
and i'll have a list and we'll sit down
talk
so he i gave him a pad of paper and he
wrote down three things and i'm like
that's it
yeah that's all i can think of and like
okay be brutally honest he said no
that's that's it
and he wrote down communication intimacy
and he felt like he could help more i
was like well that's not really me he
said but well i know i need to help more
and um
the communication has you know kind of
always been an issue
the intimacy deal is
it's hard for me because i have
fibromyalgia i've had some issues with i
think things in our past and things
early on in our marriage
um
i've been to the doctor because for
whatever reason this is going to sound
truly bizarre
but there's been times when we've been
intimate and
i will
suddenly have a like a thunderclap
headache
there's nothing strange about that
sex with your sex with your husband is
not safe for your body
so i mean i'm like and of course he's
just like wow i'm just that good huh
which is a classic thing for an idiot to
say in the middle right
i mean
he was basically you know he was like
how can i help i'm sorry i'm sorry of
course of course of course
and of course i'm like you know grabbing
my head and just like bawling my eyes
out you know the last for a few minutes
and doctors they don't know anything
about it i'm like well what'd i do and i
was like well here take this pill i'm
like i take a lot of pills thanks a lot
so here's here's the thing here's the
thing
just in the very limited things you're
telling me
sitting down and saying what are a
couple of things or what are all the
things that can make our marriage better
that's
that is a way to distance yourself
from you
and the whole crux of this book
is you looking in the mirror and saying
i need this
and you haven't done that
probably ever you may have said i want
this or it would really be nice if
but just just i'm reading between the
lines here
this guy hurt you before
yeah okay and it may have been multiple
times and for any number of reasons for
the sake of the marriage for the kids
for the appearance for whatever the
security and the financial safety
whatever the reasons yeah and i almost
left in a couple times there you go so
you've put this entity ahead of you for
a long time
and that's the way we're taught that's
why sunday school taught people that's
the way
schools and parents are
it's this thing
but if the people in this thing aren't
safe and aren't okay this thing doesn't
work right it's like focusing on the
building on the building and we don't
need steel let's just use styrofoam
because we're focusing on the building
it's like the building's gonna fall down
because the pillars aren't strong
and so instead of sitting down and
saying
hey what are the things write down
everything brutally honest that you can
make this marriage better
say
what do you need from me
to give you a life that gives you peace
so that
you can give me what i need because for
35 years you have
not and that's going to come back to oh
i do this
and you know what he's kind of right on
one of the issues on probably all the
issues i don't he's probably right
i think it's fair
when he writes communication it's not
what he thinks
but i don't know how often you've sat
down and said
i still
can't breathe sometimes when i think
about what you did
yeah well and i i told him i said
i said you have to understand i said
there are certain things that
maybe you do that maybe are are triggers
and he said well that's not fair to
punish me for
things that happen and i i'm trying to
make him understand it's not you it's
just something i have to deal with and i
am seeing somebody right now right so
listen um this idea of well you can't
punish me for that is that's
oh that language pisses me off man
because it takes somebody else's really
honestly a good guy
hold on now you're going to defend him
and that's what you've done for 35 years
stop
okay
i believe he's probably got some great
qualities awesome
you your body
is not safe with him
okay that doesn't mean he's gonna hurt
him there's yeah
right no i don't believe he won't hurt
me no exactly exactly
but right when it starts to get very
very real you roll off into trying to
defend him and protect him and it's fine
it's okay i just need to i get headaches
everyone
here's what i'm trying to tell you
you have to own what happened
period
and he's right
punishment never solves anything it just
doesn't solve it's not going to help
but right your pain and your hurt
isn't punishing him
yeah your pain and your hurt is
something you got to heal from
it's classic self-centered
the whole world revolves around me when
somebody's healing from sexual trauma
and their partner is like oh are you
going to punish me by not having sex
with me
that's like me like stepping on a nail
and i gotta get my foot healed and my
wife goes oh you're gonna punish me by
not going for a run for me just because
your foot has a nail in it yes well you
know i mean i know that i know that he
i'll put it this way we
in the past couple of years i can
probably count on
one hand the times that we've been
intimate and honestly
he has you told me at one point he said
no if we if we never have sex again it's
okay but of course it's not okay right
and you know i know he was trying to be
kind
and i know he he hates the things i have
to deal with he told me yesterday i
you know then another doctor and he said
i hate this i can't stand that you
ha you have to deal with this but i'm
kind of like
i i deal with it it's just life so let
me ask you this
this is going to sound like a crazy
question
do you want to heal
hold on hold on before you answer that i
know the like of course i don't have
headaches anymore that's not that's not
the question headaches are the alarm
system
they're just letting you know that
you're not safe you're not okay and
again i'm not a doctor i'm just making
this up it could be completely
physiological but i'm just going off
based off what you just told me just now
okay
um
if you want to heal
you're gonna have to
get with a therapist and deal with the
trauma from your past
because your body is still
responding in the present to things that
happen to you
your body has one mechanism and it's to
protect you from tigers or bears and
something happened in the past
probably multiple times as you as you
mentioned
that your brain has gps pinned him as a
bear
as a tiger he's not safe and until that
heals partly from you choosing i'm going
to go deal with this
and that means you're going to have to
deal with the consequences of what
happened
because you may have to look at him and
said you did these things
and i've got to heal from this
and then you're gonna have to say
now i'm gonna set these bricks down and
relearn what intimacy looks like with my
husband
right if that's the choice you make
or the choice might be
that i'm out i'm done with this
yeah okay but all that to say is
when i say are you ready to heal from
this
that's twofold are you ready to for real
probably for the first time
actually own this and two are you
willing to be vulnerable and risk again
moving forward
and both of those things have to be true
you cannot white-knuckle intimacy for
the rest of your marriage your bodies
continue to tell you i'm not safe i'm
not safe i'm not safe so are you
it feels here's what it feels like okay
and this is me just a picture of us
having nachos okay this isn't like i'm
not lecturing you
it feels like
you know
and it feels like he is a good guy and
he's provided for us and he's done these
things
and you want to protect him and you want
to protect the image you want to protect
the thing you all have
and your body is saying we're not okay
we're not okay we're not okay am i right
or am i wrong
yeah okay
and i don't i don't understand
completely why because
you know he
i i don't know i just feel like i'm just
so strange and i have talked to you
about it with
um the person that i'm seeing but it's
almost kind of like
i'm being told
well that's that's in the past and you
just need to you know kind of deal with
it if a therapist tells you that get up
and walk out of their office
yeah
because it's not about you just bringing
up crap from the past to throw mud in
his face
your body's literally telling you not
safe not safe not safe not safe
and it will it's all through the book it
will you will continue your body will
continue to solve for these things
until you deal with them
right do you heal from them
i did happen to tell him because um
one thing is like um her
my daughter's boyfriend he's you know
he's financially disabled and i told my
husband you know we were in debt and i
told him i said you know that's one
thing i said i sat down with this
doesn't make me feel safe
you know when i'm dealing with all this
and looking at what we have what we
don't have you know that's one thing i
did say i don't feel safe there you go
that's the language
whenever you take your clothes off
and you come towards me and i smell your
breath my body's my heart starts beating
faster and not in a good way
i gotta heal from that and i stiffen up
and i don't know why i mean it's like he
will come behind me and and hug me and i
can feel my body just that's right
and so be curious about that don't get
mad
don't get frustrated don't get angry get
curious why is my body trying to protect
me from my husband
what is it about i kind of know see
there you go you know you know
so becca if nothing else on this call
i'm giving you permission to go get well
and make no mistake
this journey will be
hell it'll be
hard because you know why your body
stiffens up
you know why
you gotta go deal with that
and that deal with that may be
confrontation it may be separation it
may be
emdr and trauma response and he's a part
of it and it may be you writing him
letters this is what happened this is
what you did to me and this is why my
body continues to respond and there's
going to be healing where your body
knows i wasn't safe then
because 30 years ago we were all
different people and 25 years ago he did
some things that hurt me that's not him
anymore
but i got to let my body know that at
one point this bear was going to eat me
and now this bear sleeps in the house
and that's the healing arc here
and that may mean that this pretty
beautiful
bone-white facade that you've created
around your life in your marriage and
your kids
it may be that it's going to crumble on
you a little bit or you have to take
some pieces down are you end up having
to move to a trailer for a while
all of that is and that's i'm being
metaphorical by the way all that is
about safety
healing your body
because touch from your
husband touched from your wife touch
from your romance
should be something that
gives your body
not the other way around
so be curious about that body response
but you don't have to be you already
know
let me say this
you're worth the healing
as hard as it's going to be
and
don't romanticize and lionize what your
daughter has cheer her on right
celebrate with her here's the deal
you're 54 so you're
you're a little over halfway done
because you're gonna live to be 100.
whenever you feel jealous be curious
about it like oh man why am i getting
frustrated when i see him
oh i don't have these three things and
then we're gonna loot back and have that
conversation again
this is ripe for counseling for you and
for your marriage um and at some point
this idea of communication this idea of
intimacy
you need to get there
but it's gonna come down to those
conversations like you've begun and
you're brave brave brave
i don't feel safe when
i don't feel safe when you touch me i
don't feel safe when we owe people money
i don't feel safe when i think you're
gonna quit all the time i don't feel
safe when you yell that has to end in
this home
and i want to learn how you can touch me
again but that means we're going to have
to go deal with what you did
and i'm going to have to forgive you for
that i'm going to set that down and then
i have to be vulnerable and risk moving
forward all these things right you got
to get a professional to walk with you
because it's been a long long long time
i believe you can do it i believe you
can do it and i'm proud of you for
taking the first step of being brave
celebrate your daughter
and then you go get well we'll be right
back
have you ever thought about how a lot of
us would drop anything to help somebody
else but we often don't give ourselves
the same level of care we spend time
energy money on everyone else
but when it comes to making time for
vacation for exercise for talking with a
mentor for sleep even going to therapy
we don't do it and we don't even realize
they won't even think about it
you are worth it
this month betterhelp online therapy
wants to remind you that you are
important
that you are worth being well and
therapy is a super important way you can
show up for yourself
betterhelp is online therapy that offers
video phone even live chat sessions with
your therapist you don't even have to
see anyone on a camera if you don't want
to it's more affordable than in-person
therapy and you can be matched with a
therapist in under 48 hours today dr
john de loni show listeners get 10
percent off their first month so decide
to invest in yourself you are worth it
and go to
betterhelp.com to get 10 percent off
that's betterhelp.com
all right we
are back let's go to james in shreveport
louisiana home of daniel cormier and
dustin poyne what's up james
how you doing dr john thanks for taking
my call you got it what's up dude
all right so
how can i just kind of stop you
that's that's literally my favorite when
somebody's like all right so uh i always
know it's gonna be good next so
all right i won't interrupt you anymore
bring it on
a girlfriend in college and uh which i
thought which was a a serious
relationship um
so we decided to
take the relationship uh to a level of
intimacy and prior to that we both were
aware that we had previous sexual
relationships so she wanted me to uh to
get tested
for sexually transmitted diseases
and so i did being the young man i was
obviously very excited
um however um i shared the you know the
results with her and whatnot and she
she never shared
her information with me um but at that
point i was you know foolish or whatnot
i
i didn't really care so we moved on um
two years after that i found out
later on that she in fact
had a sexually transmitted disease and
um
you know at that point i had it as well
and the relationship ended in a ball of
fire needless to say but um so hold on
hiv or
gonorrhea or hiv and syphilis or
chlamydia like what are we talking about
here so we're talking about hsv2 which
which is one of the non-con curable ones
right um
so
yes so she knew about this she got the
test and she went ahead and slept with
you anyway
um well
i found out that she was taking
medication for it prior to
um prior to meeting me so it yeah it had
done she's known about this for a while
what was yeah what was her reasoning why
did she
why would
one yeah why would she have you get
tested
it's not strange actually because she
got burned at some point in a
relationship and so it makes sense that
she'd want to
but it doesn't make sense that she would
say that in turn like what happened to
me i'm going to do to somebody else
yeah what was the reason
we didn't really discuss it that much um
but
i wasn't in a disgusting mood so yeah
with there she had a lot of
a lot of emotional trauma i think she at
one point was diagnosed with borderline
personality disorder so our relationship
was tough um riddled with uh i think she
had a few attempts she said she had a
few attempted suicide attempts and she
was also um
participating in self-harm behaviors
so it was how long ago was this man
this was about seven years ago okay so
yeah bring me forward here what's your
question so fast forward to now um
because of that relationship i don't i
have trouble opening up um you know one
day i'd like to share life with somebody
but i have a hard time even opening up
to
to um to relationships and just
uh trusting somebody enough to to get to
know them and to pursue like a future
and then the the second part to that is
once i do find somebody
who i trust and am willing to open up to
how do i even begin to communicate and
say hey you know i've got this
this issue that's going to be going
forward and
you know how do i
just be open and honest because there's
a lot of i think internally i've thought
about this for the last seven years
there's a part of me is upset with
myself because i allowed this to happen
and you know i made the decision to
engage
and i just
i just don't know what to do i mean it's
been seven years i haven't had any
relationships since then okay so here's
here's the thing a couple things here
number one it happened
okay
cool
yeah there's a period at the end of that
sentence
this thing happened how old are you now
27. okay so you're 20.
this happened
the number of things that 20 there's a
reason we don't let 20 year olds buy
beer they don't make great choices
okay
so let's let 20-year-old james off the
hook not off the hook you did a thing
and it it's still in
in your life right
but let's don't beat up 20 year old
james
let's come to 27 year old james and stop
trying to edit the sentence that
happened you've been trying to edit that
sentence for
eight years seven years
why did this happen what happened i
can't believe she did that it's almost a
decade of your life
right is that fair
yeah okay number two you got
fried
somebody absolutely stone wrecked you
and you gotta own that it happened
most people will go through their life
without that happening to them or it
will happen to everybody but not at that
scale and you had a bad one okay
it's similar to somebody who loves has a
loved one dies in a car wreck everybody
drives all the time every day right
there's sex going on all over the place
very few people knowingly give somebody
an sti just because
uh
they're
cruel
right
that happened to you fair
yep okay so let's own that let's put a
period into that sentence
the only thing
on the planet
that you can influence is what happens
next
and so any insight any
energy
thoughts what ifs
all of that is a complete and utter
waste of your time
because it solves nothing
the only thing you can do is say okay
what comes next
and two important things come next
number one you have to choose to be in
relationship with people
you don't have to have a romantic
relationship there's plenty people that
don't want romance that's fine you said
you do
the second thing is how do you tell
somebody you just tell somebody
and will it be embarrassing yep
are you the only one
god no you're not the only one millions
right
yeah so
the path forward i see is it's like
you're
you're running the 400 meter dash and
suddenly coach puts you in the 300 meter
hurdles three whatever it is 300 meter
hurdles
and you're like there's these things in
front and the two options you have is
not run or jump over those things when
you're running
right and so you've got more hurdles in
your path than i do
and the choice is are you going to not
run or are you going to run and have to
jump over those things when you go
that makes sense
yeah another picture listen i'm
intentionally making this more simple
than i know it is in reality
because all the sti stuff and how like
how awful you would feel if you infected
somebody and how you continually go back
and like why did i why did i what you
keep going back to those
i know those are haunting and i know
those get looped in your head and it
makes you anxious and it makes you
fearful and not trust people all that
and dude you earned not trusting people
you got hosed man
if that happened
but what i want to draw you out of this
is the very simple what happens next and
let's just say you end up meeting 10
people
10 incredible women you are attracted to
them you think they're smart and funny
and real all the things right
and 10 out of 10 of the the next 10 you
meet
you sit down and say hey before this
goes any further i got to let you know
this
all 10 of them walk away
and say thanks but no thanks
that doesn't mean that you aren't worth
being loved
that means they're not in and i'm going
to move on to number
11. is that fear
yeah yeah that's fair
and if you've got a
i'll say you got to look at it that way
because you don't want to use people as
an roi like i just want to go out with
you so you'll be my girlfriend right
but there's this sense of i'm going
gonna continue to put myself out there
because i'm worth being loved and yes my
20 year old me did something stupid and
i got burned and here we are
but i deserve being loved
i deserve being loved and deserved being
loved and also let's be honest you did
get an sti from somebody but you also
spent how long were you all together
about two and a half years okay you
spent a long time with somebody who was
struggling with a lot of things
so take the take the sti off the table
you'd still have relationship trust
issues fair
yeah and that i that's kind of like
where i'm at be right now like i've i've
come to terms with with the with the sti
but it's just like i don't even
like i don't even
i
i don't know if it's because i like the
idea of having a life partner and i
don't know i view that as like having a
family and why pick a sense that's
success you know whatever it is i know
family is a big part of of what i see in
life is value but
like i don't even
sometimes i feel like i don't even want
to trust people because of
because of the fact that i've been
burned like it it's it's not even just
you know female relationships but like
just friends in general like i just
so you don't know how to
how to even you know i can be friends
with somebody on the superficial level
but
yeah i don't know if my body just
protects or yeah protect itself
like you you walked into a beard in once
and you got your face bitten off
and
the crummy part is
all the food and nourishment in life is
in a bear den
so you gotta go back
right and your body's gonna tell you
don't go in there
we've been there and we got a face
eating off
and that's when you have to
a
learn some
right
make different choices and you gotta
risk
you gotta risk
choosing loneliness is choosing to die
young
choosing loneliness is choosing to live
a life of misery
and if you reach out and you develop
relationships and connections and you
get burned again you have a season of
grieving and you get back on the horse
and you go again it's like getting food
poisoning do you never eat again because
you got rocket diarrhea for a couple of
days no
right yeah at some point you got to go
back and eat again
yeah is that fair
yeah yeah so at some point and by the
way don't feel bad a part of my life is
also having a picture of a family in a
house and kids running around
you said that in a way that's like you
know part of my thing i kind of like
want to have a family dude that's not
weird
it's fantastic it's awesome
it's the greatest thing in the world
and you're worth the risk
is that fair
yeah yeah
i just
we do it i don't
yeah i just don't know i just don't know
like i don't even know here we go i'm
gonna give it to you i'm gonna give it
to you right at what point do i do i you
know it's like
let's say i i don't know go out on date
with somebody and it's like okay um
here's the dessert okay and here's
the reason you don't have like a scarlet
letter on you or you're like walking
around with a cowbell like unclaimed
uncle that's not you man
there's a bunch of conversations
that happen
uh not always not always there are
people that meet somebody just have sex
that day that happens all the time
doesn't sound like that's you
so there is a gap between hey let's go
out
i'm getting to know you tell me about
yourself
between that first time you go out in
dessert and by the way
um
i have this
there's
you've boxed yourself into a corner of
either never going out or on the first
date being like okay before we get going
i gotta let you know that it burns when
i pee like there's a total different gap
there right
yeah is that fair
yeah yes so
dude you're i could tell right now you'd
be fun to hang out with
i can because you're kind of chill
and you laugh good you'd be fun to hang
out with
and there will come a point when you
gotta have that conversation and your
heart will be beating fast and you'll be
nervous and the chances of you getting
rejected are high
they are that's reality that's the truth
and
you're worth that risk so real quick
real quick
go first
be vulnerable
and be hospitable what do i mean invite
people to your house stop overthinking
this have four or five people over to
play some stupid game you know what i'm
gonna send you all the cards for humans
so i'm gonna send them to you okay
you can invite people over to your house
and y'all can just use them to play like
i got these from some idiot on the radio
let's play and um
y'all can use those cards as something
to do you can have people over and say
everybody bring a thing whatever that's
being hospitable
i'm going to go first you're welcome at
my house and maybe only two show up
maybe five show maybe 12 show up i don't
care invite them all over and tell them
i'm not cleaning up by the way i'm not
going to pretend that this isn't how i
le just come over
and i'm gonna i'm gonna be vulnerable
i'm gonna risk i'm gonna invite y'all
into my place
and i'm gonna go first i'm not just
gonna sit here for the next seven years
later and wait for somebody else to call
me and wait for somebody to call me i
don't know i'm just gonna go i'm just
gonna go i'm just gonna go and you may
invite people over and zero show up none
and you grieve it
because it'll hurt
be a bummer and then you go again
because really what is the other
alternative
netflix
like a
another
i don't know fancy diet
like it move i mean what's the
alternative other than to
whoa that hurts i'm gonna go again and
i'm gonna go again and i'm gonna go
again
and that it's unpopular james thank you
so much for that call it
not speaking to you i've seen everybody
here it's unpopular mental health advice
it's unpopular relationship advice
that life really hurts
hard it's hard it's a mess when you
think you got it something happens and
when something happens and something
else it's hard
and you ultimately find yourself in
these moments where it's like what are
the other options
sit go heal and go again
sit and go heal and go again
and i'm not saying keep running back
into the same bear den don't go back
into that one ever again because you got
your face eaten off
but you got to go to another one i'm not
saying go eat you know
seven day old pizza from a nasty place
don't do that again
but you gotta eat
you gotta go find a place to eat
people got really have relationship
trauma whether it's sexual abuse whether
it's and and by the way what you
experience is trauma you experienced
abuse somebody abused you they took
advantage of you
and they forever altered your life
because of their lack of character and
their lack of integrity and their desire
to hurt you which is what they did
living in that trauma understanding that
like it happens man and then we're all
faced with this
one awful scary
devastating question what do we do now
and as for me and my friends and my
community and the people that i love and
that includes you james
i'm going to say let's get up and go
again we may have to jog and our walk
first and then jog before we get up to a
run but let's get up and go again let's
get up and go again and
let's get up and go again
you're worth it we'll be right back
john delonay here all right people
you're adults so i'm gonna talk to you
like adults and it's gonna be hard for
some of you to hear you ready it's time
to move on from the grandma hand-me-down
facebook marketplace deal or the just
plain old nasty junky mattress it's
ridiculous we upgrade our smartphones
every three months but we hang on to the
same uncomfortable lumpy mattress for
decades your sleep is too important for
that it's time to invest in a good
night's sleep with a high quality
mattress and for me that's dream cloud
i'm speaking from experience when i say
this is the easiest thing you can do to
start improving your life and your
health and dream cloud is making it even
easier with an offer exclusively for my
listeners
499 dollars in accessories plus an
additional 250 discount that's 749
dollars in accessories and savings and
you'll get pillows a mattress protector
and luxury sheets it's time to change
your sleep and your life visit
dreamcloudsleep.com deloney or
dreamcloudsleep.com and enter promo code
deloney to get your new mattress today
and get 749 in savings
all right let's go to
anne and peter pan and in houston texas
what's up anne
hey how are you just i mean incredible i
i i'm not i'm not incredible things are
fine i kind of overstated that a bit i'm
trying not to speak in hyperbole too
much but i do so i'm great how about you
you'll live in the dream oh
which is latin for not great at all at
all
oh man so what's up
so um
i don't know how to even ask this but i
think uh the best way the best way is
just like
no
no whitewash in it no trying to like
power wash it just just ask it it's
awful and weird as whatever it's gonna
be you're about to ask just go for it
i think i'm broken i don't
really love my newest child okay
um hold on hold on exhale have you said
that out loud before
uh yeah i said that to my husband okay
am i the first person not your husband
that you said that to
i know i have friends too
so no i tell everybody i i have a shirt
i don't
but i do i've got a couple girlfriends
and you know my husband but
yes
um you're not broken
i don't even know what you're about to
ask but say you're not okay okay cool
yeah you may be
like really deranged and mean but i'm
just totally kidding you're not broken
okay so you don't love your newest kid
right now tell me more about that
so um
we have three um all
have been um
adopted okay
um
and
um our first two we
um we went
domestic or their birth moms chose us
you know we had
i had them as infants and this new uh
little guy he came to us
um at almost three years old
and
uh his grandparents asked us to adopt
him
and
um
we've yeah it's i'm
doing all the things that i'm supposed
to do you know like the the really long
hot
in the skin
morning and as soon as i pick him up
from uh from child care and that night
and
like i just
you know i
it's it's like a chore i it's
um playing with him is poor and
um what what i don't know why is it a
chore what is it is is it something is
he different is he have attitude
problems is he struggling like what or
is it just no we're not connecting
i think we're just not connecting he's a
he's a pleasant child he um
his
his uh grandparents were raising him
very differently than we do he was very
addicted to scream um
he um
he didn't really have much
he struggles with speech
i think because he wasn't really spoken
to a lot um
so but but he's a charming child like
he's he's a sweet kid um
he
he's i know that with
with trauma like he's experienced just
being taken from one child uh
you know
one parent to another um i know that
that's very traumatic and i kind of
expected more behaviors
but we he he kind of is doing really
well
sometimes sometimes kids act really well
as a trauma response
yeah they know he threw a lot of
tantrums at the beginning but he's
come out of that so
um
this feeling of dislike
um
it often comes from something outside of
our picture of the way we thought things
were gonna be
yeah so what did you think was gonna be
different
than what actually is just give me two
or three of them
you know i
i had very little expectation
um about this you know um
i think i struggled with that with my
first child because i i mean i felt like
the babysitter for
months you know
um
but
um but i've i didn't have a lot of
expectations we've always wanted to have
um
you know something of a large family not
you know adoption is expensive and we're
not
you know
we don't
want 10 but
um it kind of was this ideal situation
where our children would be close in age
and you know a little guy would get a
little you know actually an older
brother and
so let me ask you this
i've had i i've had several pictures in
my life about how i wanted things to
work out
yeah and then as i've gotten really
close to that picture
it's it's changed and that change i
don't want that anymore or i get it and
i wish i didn't have it whatever it has
to it happens to be
and it's
incredibly disorienting because i've
spent however many years working towards
saving towards trying to achieve towards
and suddenly i get it
and it's not what i thought
but here i am and
you can you will let me just say this
this way you will
because you're i can tell by the things
you're you're trying right you are
leaning into this discomfort
i have no question in my mind that
you'll develop an extraordinary
relationship with this kid
the bigger concern i have is you're
gonna begin to regret your life
and i want you to make peace with that
is it that we should have stopped it too
i've heard that from people with three
and four kids our life like if we had to
do it over i love little timmy and
little susie but we would adopt it too
financially right
or um
any fill in the blank any number of
things right you can go back and play
that what if game in the variable game
all day long but what i want you to do
is to land in the middle of your life
that you're living right now
has this um young man
this little boy has he altered your
marriage
has he altered your free time your
financial life like tell me where
there's been a disruption in things
well i
i mean and if there's not it's not
that's great
it's more with my other
my other son you know like
i've always been super charmed by my
children and um
i i'm just playing
like
referee
uh all the time with and it's just it's
not fun to be around my kids anymore
there you go there you go so you see
what i'm saying the actual problem is
with the life not with the kids
yeah
um often in my marriage when i've gotten
really frustrated and i don't think i
like my wife anymore what i really don't
like is i still love her but i don't
like her and she'll tell you there's
seasons when she just doesn't like me um
she still loves me
but it's almost always the life we've
created for ourselves that we're living
in
is leading to
me to does that make sense here i'm
saying
so yeah some of the hard realities that
happened my friend says there's a huge
shift i only have two kids so i'm
speaking out over my skis here but
there's a shift that happens that nobody
tells you about
when you go from man-to-man to zone
there's a difference when you have two
kids and suddenly you go to three and
i've also heard that once you get four
five and six and eleven nobody cares
right everything's fine once you make
that other shift into that new gear but
there's something
um disorienting and transformational
about having going from two to three
just hard everything just gets harder
the the getting kids in and out of car
seats just to go to the freaking store
right or just like just need to go to
the bathroom without another human
staring at me all these things uh nate
you've got four am i right is it yes
okay so nate is in there running the
youtube cameras he's just i see him
nodding in there over and over that
there's a shift um james has 117 kids
out on the prairie and
was it similar
like going from two to three and two to
four
yeah it was a huge change going from two
to three that was a big leap okay
between the two so here's what i want
you to
look at anne this and this could be a
really fun thing how's your husband by
the way
he
is
he feels a lot of anger towards the
grandparent
so are they his grandparents
no are they your grandparents
no it's it we're not related okay
yeah why do you have anger towards your
grandparents
just um
they keep telling us things like a
little at a time like his mother is
bipolar and
oh he she was also taking this drug when
she was pregnant and
it's like they
wanted us to take him because they they
couldn't anymore
um i think like i said he's i think they
did the best they could i but they were
very lazy and um he just had a screen in
front of him all the time and
yes we kind of see the
behavior
that
came from that especially at the
beginning and
so let me tell you this yeah um and i'd
love to talk to him someday your husband
this new baby this new little boy you
brought home is not broken
yeah i know okay
um he's not like you bought a used car
and suddenly the dealer calls you once a
week it's like oh by the way the fan
belt doesn't work
right
so
listen any
any one ounce of energy
spent hating grandparents being pissed
off at grandparents is a comp is a total
utter waste of your time in life
yeah they're done i would remove them
from our life
oh we can't do that though
we're open adoption okay
i would marginalize as much as humanly
possible
yeah we we started doing that we first
invited them to our house and we saw how
nope he reacted and it just so he's been
meeting that's right so no but you know
that adoption professionals tell you
like the more that they have
contact with biological family the
better and i know i know
but hold on not in abusive situations
nobody wasn't abused he was just like
not
they were just lazy you know that's
abuse
yeah
okay yeah that's abuse
and i'll go to the mat with anybody who
wants to tell me otherwise if you take a
child
and you take human contact away from
them and you hand them a screen
that's abuse
yeah full stop
if mother's um an
addict and he doesn't get the
prenatal care that he needs and he
doesn't especially get the
post like
post birth hey we're dealing with this
he's gonna need some very direct care
because he was born an addict
um
that's abuse
he got it right so
um all that to say is this they don't
have just a willy-nilly right
because you know what he's three his
body knows
that with ann and his new dad
he's able to drop his shoulders for the
first time ever
he's able to engage and look at somebody
and what you're gonna have to do and
this is a common thing and i i'm not
putting you in this bucket this is for
everybody there's this idea that i'm
doing a good thing when i adopt or when
i foster i'm doing something good for
humanity
and because i'm doing that the cosmos is
gonna make this okay
it's gonna make this easier
you know what i mean and so i want to
give you like the reality check that you
already live which is you all chose to
adopt a three-year-old little boy who's
had lived in hell
and so it's going to be
a chore it's going to be tough walking
alongside this little boy and teaching
his brain what safety looks like and
teaching him what connection looks like
and teaching him his life outside of a
screen
all of those things are going to be a a
chore
it sounds like your husband is similar
to you that now his life is super
different and it's easy to just find
somebody to point rage at and i just
want to tell you don't do that it's a
waste of your life just don't
okay here's the thing that i think going
all the way back to us about to say
a beautiful moment would be
you and your husband get a babysitter
and y'all go spend a half day together
you don't talk about the kids as much as
you talk about okay we got three now
what do we want our life to look like
what do we want this thing to look like
what do you need what do i need what do
we need
to be okay
so that we can go back in and do this
hard thing that we're doing
and this should be a moment of dreaming
not a moment of ranting and
raving yeah there may be some seasons of
grief
like i wish we hadn't
that's okay to think that
you're not broken
it's okay to be really frustrated at
your stage of life right now
it's okay to really miss your husband
before he got angry and to really miss
man with just two little two newborns
y'all could just have sex whenever you
could go on dates when y'all can do
whatever
and now you got a three-year-old on top
of everything and i just need to go to
the bat right all that
it's okay to grieve that we had this and
now we've got this
what you can't do is let all of that
external stuff roll off on this little
boy
that now calls you a mom
yeah and he's not broken he's got some
challenges no question about it be hard
and you'll have an open adoption which i
think is great in almost every situation
when there's not abuse
and maybe grandma and granddad can come
around at some point but you all get to
set the boundaries with mom and dad
the same way i set boundaries with my
parents and my in-laws you get to set
those with grandparents and other
parents this is how we do this our kid
doesn't ever look at screens ever period
full stop he's not allowed to look at
them so if you're going to be around our
child that's just the way that's going
to work
our child doesn't eat these foods our
child goes to bed at 7 30 not midnight
or what you know what i mean whatever
the thing is
and i am going to marginalize
those
grandparents as much as is is ethically
okay right as much as it's okay
not to punish them but to help heal this
little boy
yeah
does that make sense
yeah
that
that's
what feels right um on one hand but also
you know you're a mother
you know yeah you know yeah you're not a
babysitter you're a mom
yeah
yeah and they do love him you know i
know they did love him
you don't have to protect them
they did the best they could i'm glad
they did i'm glad somebody in that
little boy's life stepped in and kept
him fed and sheltered
i'm so grateful for that and they kept
him safe good for them i'm glad they did
i wish they had different tools and they
didn't have them so great
yeah okay
um
now you guys got next level you got 2.0
little boy now we're going to teach them
how to live a whole and healthy and well
life
but a whole healthy well life for your
kids starts with you being whole and
healthy and well and your husband being
whole and healthy and well and your
marriage being whole and healthy and
well
and that all starts with us going out
and getting away from the madness
getting to a different location and
looking at each other and going so we
did a thing
now there's three
and everything leveled up as nate was
saying earlier like anyone i know who
goes from two to three like everything
just changed
it it's not we added 33 more busy we
added 100 more busy
um
and so now we gotta just adjust we might
need to get a babysitter that comes and
stays with us during the day we might
need to
get grandma i mean parents to come
whatever the thing is what do we need
and then how we're going to reverse
engineer that make that happen
keep doing the things
the one-on-one time the face
the the touching on the face touching on
the feet the hugs
the hand holds they're going for walks
keep doing those things playing in water
playing in sand tactile things keep
doing those things with this little boy
[Music]
it's going to be a tough road to hoe to
hoe no question about it keep going
so so grateful people like you are in in
this this in our communities
you are what make things better
we'll be right back
hey what's up now that my new book own
your past change your future is out in
the wild we've been hearing reviews and
feedback from readers and wow i'm so
grateful and one of the things i've been
most excited about hearing is that this
book is not just for people who are
healing from terrible traumatic
experience or other big scary things
from their past
this book is for everyone in every walk
of life the single 30 year old looking
to sharpen their mind the 25 year old
hoping to make new friends the parent
who's tired of seeing their kids eyes
glued to a screen but who doesn't know
how to re-enter their life people coming
out of abusive relationships
everyone and this book isn't me talking
at you this book is me walking with you
because i've been there too
to better understand and improve your
mental relational and emotional health
please check out own your past change
your future at johndaloni.com today
that's
johndaloney.com today
all right as we wrap up today's show man
one ah i just knocked my notes off one
of my favorite shows songs from my
childhood
fits one or two
of the calls today
from the great
the great gin blossoms and the song is
hey jealousy and it goes like this
well
tell me you think it'd be all right if i
could just crash here tonight you can
see i'm in no shape for driving anyway
i've got no place to go
and you know it might not be that bad
you are the best i've ever had and if i
hadn't blown the whole thing years ago i
might not be alone
tomorrow we could drive around this town
and let the cops chase us around and the
past is gone but something might be
found to take its place hey jealousy
and you can trust me not to not to think
and not to sleep around and if you don't
expect too much for me
you might not be let down oh this is a
guy i want to run my daughter because
all i really wants to be with you
feeling like i matter too if i hadn't
blown the whole thing years ago i might
be here with you
[Music]
something to take its place hey jealousy
we'll see you soon
coming up on the next episode my husband
and i have identical twin girls we
decided to split them up into separate
classrooms in kindergarten my one
daughter has like taken off and is
thriving my other has said zero words
and not the teachers or um other
students like we've read all the books
we've tried all the things that we can
think of and we're out of tools and
thought i would bring this to you
we've talked to the professionals we're
going to the podcast how do you have
difficult conversations with someone you
don't necessarily have a lot of buy-in
with and they don't see a problem
talking about one of my co-workers okay
myself my boss and another co-worker we
suspect that they're a hoarder this is a
great question
for
millions of people my answer to you is
don't
[Music]